Hi, I'm Ramona J. Smith, Toastmasters
International 2018 World Champion of
Public Speaking.
You may know the feeling of nervousness
or even anxiety that happens when you
have to speak in front of others without
time to prepare.
Maybe for an unexpected question during
a job interview or maybe when a teacher
called on you in class when your hand
wasn't raised.
In your professional life, you may have
even been asked to fill in for someone
else during a meeting.
I know firsthand that being put on the
spot is an intimidating speaking
challenge.
Yet, I'm one of millions of people who
Toastmasters has helped gain the
confidence to communicate in all
circumstances.
Impromptu speaking is a skill that
everyone can benefit from.
It can help you in social situations
such as weddings and birthdays or even
at work or school.
We'll start by looking at the times you
might have an opportunity to speak, then
we'll move on to techniques to manage
last-minute speeches.
Practice impromptu speaking.
Let's begin with the many opportunities
to practice speaking spontaneously.
Meetings at work or in the classroom,
whether they're virtual or in person,
can help you test your impromptu
speaking skills.
There are many other common everyday
opportunities to practice as well,
such as speaking with a bank teller,
customer service representative, or even
someone in line with you at the grocery
store.
You might be invited to attend a
wedding, retirement, or engagement
party.
These events are perfect opportunities
to practice impromptu speaking from the
heart.
Techniques.
Now that we've pinpointed a few
potential places of practice, let's take
a closer look at the techniques to help
you manage your impromptu speaking.
The first approach is a simple formula
known as PREP. P R E P which stands for
point, reason, example, point.
Start your speech by making a clear
point about a subject.
For example, internet outages are
annoying.
Next, explain why you are speaking on
the topic.
Then give a few examples to bring life
to your story, and finally, end with a
concluding point that wraps up your
speech.
Those might include things like, "I'm
speaking on this topic because it
happened today, and that is why I am at
the market waiting in this long line."
After that, you might add another
anecdote, and finally, a conclusion
about internet unreliability.
By following this flow, you'll be able
to clearly state your main point and
help keep your ideas on course.
PREP is an excellent fit for more
professional settings such as business
meetings and even interviews.
Another way to manage your speaking time
is by following the pros versus cons or
positive and negative method.
Set up an issue by addressing the pros
first, the cons second, and then neatly
wrapping up your point with your
recommendation.
Pros versus cons also works well in a
professional setting and in many
everyday settings as well.
Filling in for a speaker.
If you find yourself filling in for a
speaker, quickly think about how you
would open and close your speech.
You may begin by sharing a few personal
stories, and then engaging the audience
by acting as a moderator.
You can encourage questions and answers
to extend the speaking time if needed.
Now that you've considered how to
prepare for your speech, it's time to
concentrate on the final and most
important step,
delivering your impromptu speech.
The only way to master impromptu
speaking is by jumping in and practicing
in real time.
If you struggle with being a
perfectionist, don't stress.
Simply try to have fun.
Most people at the event will applaud
your courage and willingness to stand
in.
Stay on topic.
It's important to know one of the
pitfalls of speaking at a moment's
notice, and that is the tendency to
ramble.
The best way to alleviate this problem
is to draft an outline before you begin
to speak.
This may not always be possible, but if
you can, take a moment to write a few
notes to guide you along.
Incorporate the tips and techniques
we've just covered, you'll be amazed at
how quickly you'll have the confidence
to be a great impromptu speaker.